is the iPhone 15 Pro Max really that
much better than the 14 pro Max well in
this video I'm gonna skip the specs and
talk about my real world experience
every single difference that I noticed
day to day including multiple issues
some that others have not talked about
now I want to start out with Comfort
because people made it a huge deal that
this phone is lighter being made out of
titanium and about the curved edges when
I first took it out of the box I
definitely noticed the curved edges on
the front and back and how it digs into
your hand less it feels better and I
noticed that it was lighter but it
wasn't as big as I expected but over
this last week switching back and forth
between the two phones that is where you
really notice it you notice those edges
and you notice that extra weight now
this is something that I've wanted for a
while I thought the 14 pro Max it was
just way too heavy compared to the
Android that used aluminum and even
though the titanium does feel cheaper
than the stainless steel not as premium
I say that this design makes the max
size more comfortable to use and it
actually is slightly smaller in terms of
Dimensions I also like that my natural
color titanium doesn't show fingerprints
as much so overall that has been a nice
Improvement and the next thing are the
speakers Apple usually doesn't talk
about these but every year we have a
small Improvement this year though the
difference is huge way better than I
expected not only is it louder but you
have better bass you have crisper highs
and that is just an improvement year to
year
[Music]
I've noticed myself now using a half
volume even sometimes a little bit less
where a few years ago say with iPhone
12s I would be having it turned up all
the way so that is really nice if you
like to listen to music or watch videos
on your phone now one thing that sucks
this year is that apple is no longer
making their leather cases but I've been
buying and recommending moth products
for years and this year they have
upgraded to movas vegan leather which
has a durable and amazing texture their
power bank has some very unique features
first off it uses USBC and the port is
on the side which means you can plug it
in while using the stand both vertically
and horizontally which others can't do
and it charges both the battery and your
phone so it's perfect for the new
standby mode it's designed for ultimate
modularity so I could take my phone off
and I can charge my airpods while still
using the stand which is also my
favorite magsafe wallet ever which holds
three cards so when you're ready to
leave your house you can choose if you
want to just use the Snap-on standard
wallet or for extra power you can add
the slim Maxi battery and all three work
together so there's no need for bulky
Chargers or Gables the prices are also
great for all of these modular
accessories so check out our partner
moth's movas products using the links
down below and the next one is real
world battery life now I was worried
about this because this is the first
year that Apple has not increased the
battery life on paper while at the same
time going over three nanometer which
should have helped a lot so that was
really weird now the 14 series it kind
of sucked and I actually had to upgrade
to a Max bone just because of battery
life even though I wanted to stick with
the smaller regular 14 pro now yesterday
when this phone hit 20 I noticed it
because it was basically 11 pm after a
full day of me using it much more than
usual including 20 minutes of maxing out
the phone with a gaming throttling test
which by itself killed 10 of the battery
and using it this whole week the battery
life is absolutely better than the 14
pro Max even though Apple did not
mention it now Mr who's the boss did an
excellent test where he got almost an
hour more of battery life than the 14
pro Max which was worse than the 13 Pro
Max and in his test he is gaming and
other things so I think that if you're
somebody who doesn't play games you're
light on your phone the difference will
be even greater and I'm just so happy
that the battery life in the real world
has improved and I think that if I want
to I could actually go back to using the
regular Pro phone now another thing
Apple didn't talk about was the
connectivity speeds in particular for
cellular data now the a17 pro has the
new x70 5G chip from Snapdragon and that
is designed to have better Real World
performance and reception question and
also focus on efficiency for Less
battery usage and heat now when I test
it out inside of this concrete building
I got 394 megabit per second compared to
247. that is a massive Improvement in
real world speeds and then testing it
outside I had 440 compared to
376. now the upload was just slightly
slower but I would absolutely take this
and this is me using T-Mobile with
um the mid band 5G not super fast 5G so
I could be maxing out that connection
anyway and it is nice to see that you're
gonna have faster speeds and better
reception in the real world which makes
a big difference now one issue that I
found unfortunately is that the Wi-Fi
speeds seem to be worse and this is the
first time that I can remember where
Wi-Fi got worse year over a year now the
new iPhone 15 Pros they support Wi-Fi 6E
but this was connected to regular Wi-Fi
6 and in my basement I got 51 megabit
per second compared to 81 and then the
upload was three instead of six and then
in my backyard I got 33 megabyte per
second compared to 45 with an upload of
five versus seven this is really really
weird and
um I noticed this just because in my
basement I was looking at both phones
and my 15 Pro Max actually switched over
to 5G from Wi-Fi automatically
um and it was just really weird now this
could be a good thing if you have a poor
Wi-Fi signal it actually switches really
quickly instead of staying on that poor
signal but I don't think it should be
getting worse I don't know if it's
because of the titanium or if it's
trying to be more efficient I have no
idea but if you guys know let me know
below and now I want to mention the new
action button I absolutely love the
capabilities that it could do especially
that you can customize shortcuts I I've
set it to the camera app to quickly be
able to take a photo or video but in
this first week I have to be honest and
say that I have not been using it that
much I need to train myself to make new
habits to use it instead of just going
back to my default so maybe I will
report on that in the future but it's
definitely a nice change for me and now
I want to talk about the cameras because
when I watch their event honestly I was
a little bit underwhelmed now I want to
start out with the new 5x camera on the
pro Max because that is an exclusive and
thankfully this thing has impressed me
way more than I expected now usually
with telephoto zoom lenses the quality
actually goes down if you look at
Android phones compared to say a 3X lens
and that is because on Androids the
sensor size got smaller you had less
light hitting the actual sensor so you
can zoom in more and the quality is
better when you do that but in a lot of
cases it could be worse especially in
low light now with this 5x I was was
honestly way more impressed than I
thought I would be I was very skeptical
but even comparing 5x versus 3x it is
better in every way you get less motion
blur the quality of the photo looks
better and the portraits look absolutely
amazing with that 120 millimeter
equivalent I thought it would be too
much Zoom for portraits but Apple makes
it look great and this is something that
I'll be using very often and if you look
at Android phones I think most of them
don't allow you to take shots with that
Periscope or super zoom lens with that
smart acr5 looks much more natural HDR
for the faces doesn't look as flat as
before and in general the way that it
handles highlights and Shadows on the
face and on clothing looks so much
better than before and compared to
Android phones it looks much more like a
DSLR so I think the processing is really
nice now with that the selfie camera is
still 12 megapixels but the images look
sharper the hdrs better it looks more
natural and that is just thanks to Smart
hdr5 paired with the new image signal
processor in this phone now one concern
that I had is the quality of 3x photos
because you don't have that lens there
anymore so if you have to zoom in to
around that range it is just a digital
crop instead of an actual lens being
there and in good lighting you guys
could see the quality is definitely
worse but I was shocked that in lower
light situations the crop actually
looked better and that is just crazy now
the lens that is in the 14 pro Max and
now in the 15 Pro this whole setup is
about three years old or more so it's an
older sensor whereas with the new 5x it
is a brand new one and the 48 megapixel
is a new sensor so I think that is why
and now that I've used this for a week I
think I'm not going to be zooming to 3x
very often usually be 1X or 2X and then
switching to 5 if I need it but overall
I'm really really happy with the new 5
lens and apple did a great job even
though I would like to see an actual one
that can zoom from three to say 6X or
maybe 10x this has been nice now with
that we have a 48 megapixel Max mode
which gives you a compressed high-res
file I'm so glad Apple fixed that I
really complained about having shoot
program convert with the previous phone
now they gave the 14 pro Max that
feature as well which is amazing but
what they didn't give them is the
ability to shoot 24 megapixel photos and
when we compare the quality between 12
and 24 well it is definitely much nicer
and you can now use this for live photos
and for portrait shots and that is
really nice now they also added the
ability to make a regular shot into a
portrait shot and to be honest I haven't
really been doing it I'm so used to
putting portrait mode on that this is
something that I'm gonna have to work on
to be able to just take regular photos
and be able to change them later so
overall even though I was a little bit
underwhelmed at the event using these in
the real world I mean the difference is
very noticeable and I want to do a
comparison between multiple Generations
let me know if you guys want to see that
now the next thing I need to talk about
is the new USB type-c port I am so glad
it is there a few times I actually was
trying to find a lightning cable because
I usually use magsafe I'm like wait I
don't need to find one I can use USB
type-c and that is great of course we
have the faster transfer speeds but I
don't use that that often but I will
have to say that I'm so glad that Apple
did not limit this port you can use any
cables you can connect it to your
monitor or a projector like Vadim did
you can connect hubs to it any ssds or
SD cards work and of course you can
pre-record prores which I haven't done
yet so external media that is awesome
now as far as charging speeds Apple did
not increase the max wattage it is still
27 Watts like last year but Apple seems
to be doing some things differently the
15 Pro Max seems to hit 60 after about
30 minutes Which is higher than before
and after one hour it's at 85 percent
which is better so even though the
wattage hasn't went up they are actually
allowing it to stay higher or faster
charging for longer now to charge to a
hundred percent takes an hour 25 minutes
if your screen is off and nothing else
is happening compared to an hour and 45
minutes so that is an improvement and I
love that they're now showing Cycles in
the battery health section and they're
allowing you to limit to 80 charge which
I've been asking for for a long time
because this significantly improves
long-term battery health we have had
issues with the iPhone 14 series and
that's basically what you get with
electric cars they suggest charging to
about 80 as a daily limit and then a
hundred percent for longer trips so that
is nice and now I have to get into the
whole overheating gate or overheating
issues and I want to start out by saying
that yes I have noticed even before this
went mainstream that the this phone the
15 per Max does get hotter in the hand
when it is charging and then looking at
charging speeds that also makes a bit of
sense now what most of you guys may not
know is with the a17 pro if you're
maxing out the chip it actually Peaks at
14 watts compared to 10 to 11 in the
past so it does put out more heat and I
did a 20 minute stress test and the 15
Pro Max actually throttled faster and
the screen dimmed first and then with
that once it cooled off the screen took
longer to get back to regular brightness
it took about two minutes instead of one
now of course we have the new titanium
Apple showed off how they bonded the
titanium to the aluminum and titanium is
not as good of a conductor as far as
heat compared to aluminum or stainless
steel like on the old phone now if you
look at the 20 minute test during the
beginning the performance is actually 25
better or even a little bit more at the
start but by the end of the first run
the overall difference was just 13 not
20 like they advertise so yes throttling
is affecting it and it throttled quicker
than the 14 pro Max now if we compare
the lowest scores for both which was run
18 the 15 Pro Max was 18 faster so close
to that 20 speed so once both of these
throttle which they do the performance
is still increased on this new phone so
it's not a huge deal now you do feel the
phone get hot that is absolutely the
case and looking at the thermal footage
I think we know why you see the heat you
actually see the chip there the outline
of it compared to the 14 pro Max where
the heat is much more spread out and I
think Apple definitely needs to put in a
cooling system maybe Vapor chamber or
other things like Androids have been
doing for years I don't know why they
are not doing that but I have to say
that in the real world for my normal
usage almost always I'm not having any
issues of this phone getting too hot we
have the new efficiency cores that are
much improved so they are being used
more often with basic tasks and the 5G
chip is also more efficient so this is
not something that I would really worry
about and to be completely honest when
Apple announced this phone and in my
first video I said that this was one of
the most underwhelming updates in many
years the regular 15 seemed good but
these ones not so good but after using
it for a week I'm actually much more
pleasantly surprised than I was at the
event it is not a massive update but
there's a lot of small things that have
been improved you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comments section
below click that Circle above to
subscribe because we have a lot of other
great videos coming out check out one of
those right over there that's been Max
and I'll see you in the next one
foreign